Peggy's 16
okay Natalie Dormer plays Lexie to pero
who is the doctor on board the tempest
she's an asari Scott rider the
Pathfinder wants you or on your feet
right away when she's got some
experience and wisdom under her belt and
in that way she's able to advise the
player she isn't without emotion or
compassion um so she sort of tries to
walk the line of just the professional
doctor but sometimes she takes over it
it's a seizure her brain can't handle
the connection she's got some great wry
lines some dry humor in there it just
means you're still shaking off your nap
sorry that's the last book in the series
the author died before it was finished
it's so huge and the production value on
this series is just extraordinary every
single discipline within the project is
at its top level from the design to
hopefully acting involved too just every
single level of production it's people
at the top of their game I had a bit of
a moment earlier when getting Anthony's
voice came in over across my cans haha
he's doing a voice of Gil
in Andromeda it's kind of a weird one
hearing Renly Baratheon and Margaery
Tyrell in different guises dead uh
[Music]